Chad's president is meeting niger's
co-leaders to negotiate a peaceful end
to the crisis it follows an ultimatum
issued by the West African Regional
block warning coup leaders to reinstate
the president within one week or face
military action
coup supporters gathered in their
thousands in the capital in the Army
some of them attacked the embassy Gates
of the former colonial power France
Sarah khairat begins our coverage
what started as a peaceful protest by
Pro coup supporters in Niger against
France turned into this
[Music]
they came out in their thousands in the
capital and some tried to break into the
French Embassy
chanting down with France their message
to the former colonial power was clear
to not meddle in the Jazz Affairs
[Music]
I would like to say to the European
Union the African Union and ecowas
please stay out of our business
people are suffering in this country or
shouldn't be living like this we're
coming out to support the forces because
they're here to bring us balance
after Wednesday's coup the head of the
presidential guards unit General
abdulrahman shiani declared himself
niger's new leader but France an ally of
Al said president Muhammad bazoom has
condemned the Takeover along with the EU
and the West African Regional block
echoas leaders have gathered a
neighboring Nigeria for an emergency
Summit the block has called for the
immediate reinstatement of president
bazzoon
I believe that all means will be used if
necessary to restore constitutional
order in Niger but ideally everything
should happen in peace and harmony
for their part the coup leaders say they
took power because of the lack of
security economic troubles and
Corruption and they are warning against
what they say is an imminent threat of
military intervention by ecos forces
the objective of this meeting is to
agree a plan of aggression against Niger
through an imminent military
intervention in yemi in collaboration
with African nations not members of the
organization and certain Western
countries
the EU and France have already suspended
security cooperation and financial aid
to Niger with France warning that any
attack on its Nationals will have
consequences
Al Jazeera
let's bring in Ahmed Idris who's at that
ecowas meeting in Abuja Ahmed first of
all what exactly do we know about what
Chad is proposing to try and end this
crisis
the details are kept close to the chest
of West African leaders and the chardian
president his presence in Abuja today
was no coincident looking at the events
in Niger
also the presence of other West African
leaders attending the summit and also if
you if you remember in the early days of
the coup
Niger refused entry to certain West
African delegations in fact the
president of Benin Republic was supposed
to be there then eventually after
meeting President of Nigeria with
chairman of ecowas that meeting was
canceled now we understand although not
officially we understand that President
Idris Debbie is going to mediate to
bring that crisis to an end and also
deliver the message of the West African
leaders there
and Ahmed How likely how serious is the
prospect of military intervention by
ecowas looking
we we haven't seen Echoes intervening
militarily for a very long time the last
successful one was in 2017 when Yaya Jam
was trying to stay put after he was
defeated in the elections but with the
with the saber rattling uh around with
from ecowas from the European Union from
the United States in even United Nations
that people are taking this very
seriously but the big question is who is
going to foot the bill and who are going
to send in troops into Nigeria yeah
Nigeria has a bigger Force than most of
these countries
but will other countries join in to uh
sort of send the message to the military
coup leaders in near me that is what we
don't know at the moment
all right we'll leave you there thanks
so much